salut peuple de l'internet qui regardent
des vidéos sur internet
du coup en ce début de semaine c'est pas
du tout cette vidéo qui était prévue
pour aujourd'hui mais j'ai une idée ce
week end et je vous avoue que je suis en
mode obsessionnel depuis trois jours là
dessus sur une nouvelle méthode qui
permettrait de retenir des longues
séquences de chiffre alors longue tout
est relatif mais ça pourrait être par
exemple pour retenir un code à 30
chiffres je sais pas pourquoi mais de la
nuit de vendredi à samedi je divague et
un peu peut-être à cause de tout ce
fromage à raclette que je mange en ce
moment et je me suis dit quand je
retiens des séquences de chiffres par
exemple si vous suivez la chaîne ou que
vous êtes procuré mon livre vous savez
que tous les ans je mémorise un code à
12 chiffres qui me permet de savoir quel
jour de la semaine tombe n'importe
quelle date de l'année je vous mets
d'ailleurs la vidéo qu'on avait faite
avec un mix m sur le sujet ici là deux
solutions pour mémoriser ce genre de
séquence soit vous utilisez une
technique comme celle que je vous
explique de la table de rappel du palais
mentale ou de visualisation ce qui va
vous permettre de retenir l'intégralité
mais dans un ordre précis c'est à dire
que vous êtes obligés de passer par le
début pour pouvoir après tout en vidéo
vous pouvez pas accéder à l'une des
informations à un placement précis avec
une table de rappel c'est possible mais
c'est un petit peu lourd pour faire
juste ça soit vous faites comme moi vous
séquences et c'est à dire que ce code à
deux chiffres j'imagine 4 code à trois
chiffres
et quand je dis j'imagine c'est au sens
littéral dans ma tête j'ai un blog un
bloc un bloc un bloc et c'est des petits
blocs de trois donc si je cherche le
septième je sais que c'est le premier du
troisième bloc voyez l'idée est là
justement je suis en train d'apprendre
mon code pour l'année prochaine je
préfère me mettre à jour tous les ans
même si un même code ce que durait
quatre ans et c'est là qu'a eu un truc
bizarre là dedans je sais pas pourquoi
aucune idée mais j'ai pensé aux
partitions des musiciens cd partitions
les tablatures de guitare par exemple
soit des partitions classiques pour
mettre ça q sol de fa de bien de ce que
tu veux tu as fait fabien jeux de mots
et dans l'idée je me suis dit est ce qui
serait pas plus performant de visualiser
ces blocs de chips et séquence là dedans
la deuxième méthode dont je vous parlais
en les mettant sur des lignes
différentes vous voyez là par exemple m
342 757 338 etc etc je viens d'essayer
pour une partie des décimales de pi
oui je sais je je m'éclate eh bien ça
marche beaucoup mieux parce que vous
savez que j'essaie d'apprendre qu'ils le
plus possible alors ça ça va j'utilise
des palais mental un peu de synesthésie
j'ai ma méthodologie pour ça je vous
avais fait une vidéo sur le sujet vous
avez le lien ici mais pour les séquences
et c'est plus compliqué hélas pour les
séquences et c'est mortel ça va trois
quatre fois plus vite
enfin j'ai l'impression d'une beaucoup
plus performant le même manière j'ai
appris mon code pour l'année prochaine
comme ça en un claquement de doigts dans
ma tête je les range est comme ça sans
faire d'image pour un cumul chips est
juste de données brutes en les plaçant
comme ça il y en les visualisant et ça
s'est accroché direct ça s'est accroché
dans ma tête depuis deux jours je fais
des recherches sur le net je demande à
des gens qui s'y connaissent en mémoire
et mnémotechnique personne n'a entendu
parler d'une méthode comme ça donc c'est
une piste que je lance voilà ça m'est
venue il ya quelques jours
si ça vous dit de creuser avec moi là
dessus de voir ce qui est possible
d'essayer de vous en servir et de voir
s'il en sort n'hésitez pas à me faire
vos retours par mail vous avez le même
mon mail il est dans la description
toujours et on pourrait voir comment
utiliser ça je sens bien en fait il ya
quelque chose d'encore plus intéressant
à faire avec ça mais j'ai l'impression
d'avoir créé un outil comme un marteau
mais j'ai pas encore les touts les clous
qui existent que je pourrais utiliser
avec où est ce que je veux dire
en tout cas je trouve ça génial si le
fait d'avoir fait des vidéos avec vous
pendant un peu plus d'un an et demi ça
me permet aussi de créer de nouvelles
méthodes et nouvelles pistes sur la sur
la mémoire
ma foi c'est formidable donc si vous
avez des sources sur le sujet peut-être
que ça existe déjà fait en moi par si
vous vous en servez que vous vous rendez
compte que c'est plus simple pour vous
pour faire autre chose que vous avez une
utilisation de l'idée de la partition
mental vous pouvez m'en faire part
et puis si vous avez juste des idées que
moi je pourrais creuset de mon côté
genre ouais mais avec ça je me dis que
tu pourrais faire ça ça ça vous me le
dit dans les commentaires et on fera une
suite à tout ça et moi je me pencherai
sur le sujet c'est ma petite passion du
moment
je pense que j'ai de focus là dessus
pendant un mois n'oubliez pas de cliquer
de vous abonner si vous découvrez la
chaîne pour la première fois et rendez
vous fin de semaine en torrent
la vidéo sur le vendredi mais là il ya
une petite particularité donc ce sera
que ce week end et je vous embrasse
ciao
[Musique]